andy grove um one of the founders of
intel and
he said uh bad companies are destroyed
by a crisis good company survive account
racist but great companies are defined
by a crisis
i want us to be that third bucket and
you know what so much of its mindset
if you think you're going to win if you
think that this is going to
define you in a positive way and you're
going to learn something from it and
it's going to make you stronger
it kind of happens right like so much of
your mindset of the leader becomes the
psychology the organization
and that psychology really becomes a
collective consciousness that
mana it becomes real and so
so that was the thing and we said every
single opportunity is a moment we have
to pivot move fast
so what actually happened was first of
all you have to have the mindset a
mindset of hope of optimism of
resiliency that we're going to get
through this
and now we're going to get through this
but every one of these crises is going
to lead to a new point of innovation
let's look for moments and the moment
happened
we uh with social distancing we had to
shut down in person experiences
everybody's known for homes but we also
have three hour activities that you can
book with people all over the world do
really cool activities
they got paused suddenly you know we
started doing listening sessions with
our host it's important by the way to
listen and
um be curious and some of the you know i
don't think it's much in life you have
to have ideas
as much as be a receiver for ideas like
it's not my job to have an idea and it's
not our job for any of us having ideas i
think we need to be receivers we're like
radio antennas like we just gotta
get on the right signal and and they'll
tell you people will tell you things
and people told us they wanna host um
but they can't do it in person can they
offer them online
and at first i thought to myself no you
can't offer them online we're about
connection and connections in the real
world then i thought to myself
well that's the case there's not going
to be a lot of connection anytime soon
so
i quickly realized and we quickly
realized yeah we should get in on this
and um within 14 days we pivoted
the entire product line to offer online
experiences so now you can do we have
800 experiences
200 olympians so we did a nine-year
partisan olympia with the olympics
200 olympians including jackie joyner
kersey you may remember from the united
states
olympics and um and then we had um tony
hawk didn't experience
um so they did these like activities and
you actually can meet them and go on
kind of remotely be on experience with
them and so we did that but i think so
much of it as
turning on a dime i never wanted to just
be focused on survival
if you focus survival that's probably
all you're going to get and so i said i
don't want to focus on survival and so
while
all these other companies i saw were
like kind of
you know like just shuddering their
businesses and just in defensive mode
and preservation mode
i think preservation mode is a very
dangerous place to be
and i think the more resources the
company accumulates
the more they start worrying about
losing things like a parent with an
overactive amygdala
worrying at the child is gonna like and
putting the helmet on the child before
they go outside you're worried
something's gonna happen at some point
they never lived their life
right you gotta like the same thing with
a company you
yeah you gotta be like concerned but not
so concerned
that you protect the company from itself
and you're afraid to do anything
and you're just preserving resources and
it and actually that's the worst
possible thing
ironically for shareholders right
shareholders need the company to grow
right so this weird like obsession
sometimes
that some people have with serving
shareholders it's not actually
it's not it's not in the shareholders
best interest they need companies to
create value
and therefore they need to be focused on
doing new things people love that's what
needs to happen to create value
[Music]
you